it looks like the classic Bella machina
an artifact of the Golden Age of Italian
sports cars but this one is not a bitoni
or a pininfarina creation it was
designed and built single-handedly by
johannes paulson
the bear adeno is a two-seater in the
tradition of the 1960 sports cars
Johannes Paulson has been honing his
personal automotive vision for more than
50 years now at 17 he began dreaming of
a super sports car one that would
surpass the ferrari 275 or the ford gt40
he explains that his original idea was
not necessarily to build his own car
just to own one but when he showed his
father what cars like that cost he was
told he would never be able to afford
100 discussed da matza the bear Rodino
may look like a pricey sports car by one
of the elite makers but nearly every
part of it was designed and built by
policin himself for the visual and
technical quality that impresses even
the experts the automotive technology
graduate put around 7,000 hours into it
from the first drafts to the completed
automobile
the essence what he says the drawings
were the first step but the first
sketches he made when he was seventeen
were a bit immature they began looking
more professional after he learned
technical drawing as a student he based
the car on the final drawings he still
thinks his final design images were
quite good was he an organisation mom
devon shown an admiralty scootin
perfecting sue stock to finalize the
design policin had to fashion a 3d model
of the body he says only when he started
building the model did the project take
on the third dimension and the
appearance of the actual car making it
was a piece of work that's fine i'd know
it by the late 1960s he was creating
true to scale models from plaster he
made the final draft design on a scale
of one to one
you
Allison build a negative mold and
laminated the Baron Dino's body and
fiberglass reinforced plastic after
seven years in the making the bear Adina
was ready to roll policin acquired the
mechanical components like axles and the
engine from Porsche the 110 horsepower
engine swiftly carried his thousand
kilogram creation to a speed of 200
kilometers an hour a respectable
performance for the early 1970s in 1975
the Baron Dino got the blessings of the
state inspectors policin explains that
he was in constant contact with the
state inspection point in cologne the
only one that is authorized to deal with
prototypes he had tailored the interior
of the barely one metre high Baron Dino
to his own one meter 70 height and
located the instruments in the center
console to save space the two liter
6-cylinder boxer engine from the Porsche
911 is mounted in the rear unusual are
the auxiliary instruments in the engine
compartment policin calls it a service
panel and it's unique to the bear Adina
it comes in very handy when he services
the engines he can even start the engine
from the back when he synchronizes the
carburetors he put all the instruments
needed for the 911 engine in the rear
such as the oil pressure and temperature
gauges don't meter
Alison even build various model versions
of his bear adeno besides the fastback
there's a notch back with a different
hatch and if so desired he can even
convert the sports car into a breezy
roadster the convertible is version 3
and policin sees a bright future for the
bear Adina short thought safe he says
he's got plans for modernizing the car
to make it attractive to today's drivers
it's not a matter of copying the now
vintage sports car but of redesigning it
with cutting-edge components and
technology son on mama says an auto for
now Afghanistan with Madonna technique
Collison is on the lookout for partners
willing to contribute to the new bear
Adina that would make Johannes Paulson's
dream come true to see the spirit of the
borough Dino live on